what questions do you have about bitcoin
eight look at that 890 when'd you buy it
so i bought it
at i think 14 it went to
19. i sold it at 16. oh so you made
money then
about even yeah on it uh what well
bitcoin
you want the tr let's see the 2007
bitcoin is a
in my mind just one big ponzi scheme
okay why
the 2017 video you have by the way
bitcoin marty says hello
that [ __ ] bitcoin marty he's part of
first of all all the people i know in
bitcoin bitcoin marty
bubbly gang our people caleb that caleb
yeah he told me to stop bash he's like
he didn't stop bashing people yeah
he came on he came on the podcast he
laid it he he understands it now
i understand what i think you guys think
it is
to me it is a ponzi scheme that you get
in
and and you just gotta not be the one
held left
holding the bag i'm gonna give you ammo
for the finance world and then i'm going
to tell you why bitcoin's the solution
well and i know it is it's gold and
pumping money and there's set i mean
the stock market you know you say it
always goes up it's like that 45 degree
angle correct
since 1971 direct 45 degree angle a
couple of drops whatever but it's
straight up that's because it's
denominated in dollars they're just
devaluing the dollar right
stocks go up if you denominate that same
stock market
in gold the stock market is down since
1971.
it's all the stock market is a complete
scam in terms of
accruing value it's all the dollar being
devalued so it goes straight up 45
degree angle
but if you denominate it in ounces of
gold it's down
okay so okay well here's a different
language but no here's what
here's why it's important to go to no
here's why it's important
uh you bought a house right in uh where
uh a lot of places nantucket yeah i have
one there yes
okay why'd you buy that house in
nantucket i love that place
okay i mean i loved it is that that's
not something i was trying to get
like i thought i'd live there the rest
of my life okay and there wasn't that
many to
select from right yes okay and because
there's not that many the prices are
expensive and you have a lot of money so
you could buy right yes
okay same thing in the digital world is
there some things that are just scarce
and if those things end up having a
large community that wants them
what ends up happening the price goes up
go up correct okay so bitcoin's only got
21 million
obviously and the whole thing behind it
is the strongest computing power in the
world so literally the computer network
that runs bitcoin
is stronger than anything in the world
no government nobody can hack it because
it is the strongest computing network in
the world it's got more computing power
on it than anything else
the reason why that's so important is
because the
whole idea of like why does barstool
work it's because you guys are
completely decentralized like nobody if
they try to like come at you they get
attacked by all these other people at
bar stool
right and that decentralized type media
model where you're not going and telling
somebody okay send me your thing i'm
gonna be the editor and then like i'm
gonna approve it
it's just like here's a [ __ ] camera
go post on your accounts and like just
blow it up right and do it that's the
same type of thing that's going on
but with money now so rather than the
government saying uh hey today we're
gonna print more money or
remember what happened today with penn
where they just all sudden all these new
shares right
you're like [ __ ] what the hell like i
had no say in this right that's
basically what the federal reserve does
so earlier this year they printed three
plus trillion dollars
you didn't get a vote i didn't get a
vote just [ __ ] okay
whatever cash you have so let's say
you're worth 200 mil and let i don't
know
30 million dollars in cash right that 30
million of cash if you leave it in cash
is gonna be worth less next year worth
less next year right because the
purchasing power goes down
and so what ends up happening is you're
financially incentivized to get out of
the dollar and
buy stocks buy gold but you know buy
[ __ ] property whatever
but with bitcoin they can't do that
because there's only 21 million and a
computer runs it so the only way to
change the computer is if
more than half of the people agree to
change what the computer does
so there's no person there's no like old
guy in a suit who basically is like i
think that we should print more money
or ah you know what we should take some
money in circulation no human is
involved in making the decision
it's the consensus of everyone involved
so
the reason why it becomes so valuable is
because nobody can [ __ ] with it
and that's why the bitcoiners are so
like rabid about it is they're just like
it doesn't matter what anybody says what
you think i think anybody
nobody can [ __ ] with it and because it's
like that
on the internet and globally everyone's
subjected to the same rules
it continues to accrue value because
people realize wait a second they're
[ __ ] with the dollar they're [ __ ]
with the euro they're [ __ ] with the
yen the r b
whatever but the only thing you can't
[ __ ] with is bitcoin and so
as that keeps going you should just take
one to five percent
of your net worth put in bitcoin don't
look at it just leave it there
and that'll be the best performing thing
in your entire portfolio
if you take one percent out of
everything else in your portfolio
whether you own real estate stocks
anything what's one percent gonna give
me
well let's say it goes up 20 x
what's one per what's one percent of 200
million i don't have a 200 million but
was one percent so a million dollars i
make 20 million and what how long
so there's something called the having
i'm sure that they've all told you about
this but basically the whole idea is
every four years the amount of bitcoin
that shows up every day
gets cut in half so it used to be 50
bitcoin a day or a 50 bitcoin every 10
minutes then it was 25 bitcoin every 10
minutes and 12 and a half now it's at
6.25
that just happened in may it got cut in
half again every time that that's
happened the next 18 months bitcoin's
gone up an incredible amount because
it's a
supply shock right it's like think of it
as uh if we all wanted
something and then bitcoin at right now
like 10
500
do you remember when you first started
buying it well i bought way back in the
day
yeah what was the price more than that
was over ten thousand yeah i think so
i bought it in that huge rush when
everyone was yeah but it was only it was
only above 10 000 for like
20 or 30 days so you would have to
really have bad timing i thought it was
close to like 20
it went to it went from ten thousand to
twenty thousand in eighteen days in
2017. so i probably bought around
fifteen or sixteen
okay you still have it or you saw it's
lost
it was in one of those keychains you
lost it yeah that was another part it's
like i don't
i don't like having to hold [ __ ] in like
keychains and weird
and like uh marty how much how much did
you have
probably 50 grand marty like had to do
it
yeah yeah yeah he helped you and then he
gave it he gave you the he gave me
something with the weirdest kind
he lost like yeah it's gone okay so
i lost that but i i'd be down on that
and that was what 2017.
yeah but you got to remember but you got
to understand that the markets the way
that they work is
so that having happens it goes up a
bunch in prices or supply shock usually
takes about 18 months for that to happen
then it draws down 85
it's happened three times already yeah
right well the thing why i say
it's like so i got out i i really
this latest round i think i had 1.25
million in it at one point
went up went down and then went back and
i was like i absolutely don't know what
the [ __ ] this is it's too much money to
not
like at least with stocks even though i
don't believe half the [ __ ] they say
like okay our stock got tanked today i
can do a direct
like line to we do the stock offering i
know or
earnings or and what i don't like i
think a lot is [ __ ] i think the
day-to-day like
but i understand it's like almost like
watching a sports game like
all right my team lost i bet a minus two
they lost by three i lose my money
bitcoin i have no [ __ ] like there's
no rationale why is it going
i have no idea why someone else think of
like a uh a technology company
when barcelona first started actually
it's a great idea you didn't have a
stock price
right correct so it was just every day
the only person who saw the
p l or whatever it was if you guys even
had one right right and
if there was a stock price in the early
days of barstool it'd be like in the
morning it would be through the roof
right by the afternoon to be down and it
was basically like what you emotionally
felt there's highs there was lows
it was like super volatile you're like
are we gonna [ __ ] survive are we not
whatever
super super volatile but because you're
a private company there's no stock price
so if you think of bitcoin it's really a
technology
right and has that same volatility that
bar stool had or other tech companies
have
it's just that there's a price
associated with it so what you're seeing
is you're seeing all that incredible
volatility
but like imagine if uber the first
couple of years
what is that what is that based on
emotion right now no
well it's price discovery right so think
if you think of bitcoin
people are buying and selling bitcoin to
me
did you hear about this guy mike uh
microstrategy what he did
microsoft i saw that my travels but i
didn't like research it but it was pop
popping up like on my 500 his 500
million dollars on his balance sheet
publicly traded company over a billion
dollar valuation he took 85
425 million dollars of out of dollars
and put it in bitcoin
and the reason he said is if i leave
this in cash it's going to get devalued
so every year that i sit with this cash
it's going to be worth less and less and
less so i moved into bitcoin now that's
a really really aggressive move
right of course but if you think about
from a personal perspective
one every investment you make you want
asymmetry
right if you if you think about the best
investors in the world they're right
like 55-60 percent of the time so all
these guys who are like all them right
every time they're all [ __ ] [ __ ] up
right well whoever right they're all
foolish
the absolute best investors in the world
right 55 to 60 percent of time
but they only put trades on where it's
like
i can lose 10 or i can make 20 times my
money right so asymmetric in their favor
that they're willing to take kind of the
losses 45 of the time because the 55
percent of time they're right it just
pays for it right so what you want to do
is create a portfolio of
assets that have asymmetry right so penn
stock has asymmetry
in a sense it's not going to go to zero
right it can go up a lot bitcoin has
asymmetry in that yeah maybe it drops
down but it drops 10 20 percent
but it also can go to you know hundreds
of thousands of dollars right
and then what you want is you want a
bunch of stuff that's non-correlated so
if you have penn stock and then six
other stocks and they're all
moved together so when pen goes down
they go down
well then just put it all in [ __ ] pen
stock why do you have all six of them
right because they all move together
but what you want is you want different
types of assets so you want bitcoin you
want pen stock you want whatever
and then what ends up happening is if
pen stock's down that doesn't
necessarily mean that bitcoin is up or
down there's just no correlation right
although
bitcoin lately seems to be tied to
what's going on the stock market
good observation so in liquidity crisis
right and since march basically
the reason why the fed pumps so much
money in is because everyone [ __ ]
panics and says like to me
my original gut was if you asked me
before
like this would be beneficial to bitcoin
but it hasn't been
it's the best performing asset this year
like from an asset class
it's up like 60 percent when you say
asset so think
stocks precious metals crypto like
whatever
right so yes there are individual stocks
that perform better than some but as a
whole
stocks are basically up single digit
percentage from year to date
gold's up like 20 25 bitcoins up over 50
right so it's outperformed all the other
ones on like a asset class basis
and the whole thing is uh they're
pumping all this money people are scared
of inflation they run to inflation hedge
assets
precious metals real estate whatever but
bitcoin's the most volatile
and so it dropped 50 percent a single
day earlier this year like right
scares the [ __ ] out of people right but
then when everything goes up it just
goes up more than everything
and it doubly scares the [ __ ] out of
people i think in
in part of my i know what you're saying
like what sakashi or whatever the [ __ ]
this is
it there's nobody count i'm an
accountability guy so
like nicola you know that guy was a
fraud and he's like
i like knowing even if you stole my
money i like knowing who stole it
i can be like this [ __ ] guy so you
see i think he deleted his twitter
account
he did he did yeah he got out he got
called out and
so to me is that what's worse losing
your job or having to delete your
twitter account like would you rather
get kicked out of barstool or have to
delete your twitter account
i mean i have no problem deleting i'll
just come out like michael paper
michael scott paper company i got like
lots of names i can do so i'm not
worried about that
but you know that's part of the thing is
bitcoin
and i get like i understand what you're
saying but still
there's an unease and maybe it's i also
have a
like i don't put my toe in the water
yeah i generally like
jump in like all right i want to make
like 10 grand i don't know if i can do
that i want to put
millions into something like if you
looked at what i'm doing right now
like that's why i got caught with my
hand in the cookie jar with my own
[ __ ] company
it's like but that's how i operate so
not knowing being like
do you think penn stock or bitcoin
performs better through the end of next
year
that's a tough one well it makes you
think